[Musique]
elisabeth de feydeau bonjour moi
j'appelle munich
merci d'être à nouveau sur le plateau de
tv fil 78 pour de nouvelles aventures
car votre vie pleine de rebondissements
voilà vous avez participé déjà à la
création du musée nom du grand musée du
parfum
voilà qui est ouvert ses portes
récemment windows et des bassins ouverts
le 15 décembre donc ça c'était
l'inauguration avec ouverture au public
le 22 décembre 73 rue du faubourg
saint-honoré c'est juste en face du
bristol 8 dans le viiième d'accord alors
quelle a été votre rôle je crois qu'il
ya eu ces experts qui ont travaillé à la
conception de ce musée absolument don
josé marti à douala
mouais nous ont intitulé conseiller
scientifique et culturel pour tous le
parcours historique qu'elle se situe
donc au 1er - raymond qu'on est dans les
sous-sols pas ce que ça veut dire
voilà donc en fait un très bel hôtel
particulier sis vrai qu est l ancien
hôtel particulier de castelbajac
donc c'est un côté de l'élysée avec un
magnifique jardin enfin c'est un lieu
enchanteur et il ya de très très beaux
sous sol indique t elle celle ordinaire
dans lequel donc on a construit un
parcours historique d'accor donc c'est
vous qui est et les voilà reste ce voilà
donc j'ai été à l'initiative à tout
début la réalisation à la réalisation et
puis également sur tous les contenus
scientifiques culturels voilà qui donc
l'a par exemple on voit la galerie des
séducteurs est décédé c'était en fait
pour moi c'est une sorte de cri frise
chronologique au travers des histoires
d'amour qui ont été marqués par la
présence du parfum un accord comme
complices comme trublion donc il ya
comme ça des histoires visite histoire
en fait deux de couple alors soit des
couples d'amoureux soit des couples de
rencontres en fait qu'ils appartiennent
à la même époque
et ça m'a amusé en fait de raconter
l'histoire du parfum de cette manière et
vous avez un exemple par exemple un
exemple par exemple un exemple par
exemple eh bien vous avez un exemple de
ne pas très de marc antoine et cléopâtre
la reine d'égypte qui part à la
rencontre de son futur concurrent
marc-antoine qu'elle va séduire
d'ailleurs et al franc son plus beau
navire et elle fait parfumer les voiles
de parfum en l'ouvrant au point comme le
dira plus tard décrira plus tard
shakespeare dans sa tragédie antoine et
cléopâtre le vent en fut malade d'amour
c'est une très jolie histoire et on
raconte aussi que leur première nuit
d'amour s'était déroulée dans un matelas
de pétales de roses et les histoires
lire d'accord et vous avez fait quoi
d'autre dans ce musée
alors ce musée dont il ya cette galerie
ensuite vous avez aussi un endroit qu'on
appelle le temple puisque l'histoire du
parfum des mains dans les temples dès
l'antiquité et donc on se retrouve dans
un temple égyptien mais aussi
gréco-romain on va parcourir toute cette
histoire ont finalement le parfum était
offrandes aux freins de dieu également
un souvent le pouvoir d'achat travers
les siècles parfums les aromates comme
on les appelait sous l'antiquité c'était
le prix de l'or donc forcément détenir
les routes des parfums c'était avoir une
richesse et non mais c'est ce qu'on va
très bien avec l'histoire d'alexandre le
grand
donc on a comme ça des multimédias qui
vous présente un certain nombre de pans
historique de cette thématique et puis
aussi on a la chance d'avoir le prêt de
très très beaux flacons qui viennent
essentiellement de la collection drawn
qui appartient donc à la famille thorpe
et qui normalement à munich mais qui là
lui qui n'a elle pas de l'egypte
ancienne jusqu'à l'ain jours donc on a
un très très très belles heures n'a
d'explication à son exceptionnel n'était
jamais sorti munich et qui sont prêtées
au grand musée du parfum et puis on a
bien sûr le musée grâce à la muse et la
parfumerie à grasse qui nous a prêté et
aussi certains flacons donc ensuite
quand vous passez du temps vous allez
vers un cabinet de curiosités on va
courir toute l'histoire du parfum en
occident entre le moyen-age est
également la fille de cours donc la fin
du xviiie siècle
on parcourt cette histoire le parfum à
la fois porter remède mais aussi était
un instrument d'hygiène et là encore une
parure qui permettait d'aller voilà
d'être devant le roi à la cour de
versailles notamment d'accord et puis
dernière partie de ce parcours c'est
l'essor de la parfumerie moderne avec
toute cette naissance de la parfumerie
au 19e siècle parfumerie moderne ans à
venir en vitrine et ben c'est
l'industrialisation c'est à dire que le
parfum va faire cette mutation
incroyable de l'artisanat vers
l'industrie c'est à dire qu on est plus
sûr des senteurs naturelles
on est sur des odeurs de saintes a alors
ya également il ya d'une part la
mécanisation donc ça va être toutes les
usines qui seront construites en
périphérie de paris pour la fabrication
la fabrication des produits finis dont
des parfums et les matières premières
ça reste dans sud sa grâce et puis il ya
donc la mécanisation il ya eu aussi
toutes les premières applications de la
chimie organique à la parfumerie toutes
les premières applications des notes de
synthèse preuve a fait renaître
finalement le parfum l'art du parfum
aussi puisque le parfum va pouvoir
s'affranchir des lois de la nature et
donc on retrace cette grande épopée
si vous voulez de cette parfumerie
moderne la naissance de la marque aussi
la naissance des grandes maisons
parfumerie et puis aussi l'avènement
puisqu'on est à paris des couturier
parfumeur avec paul après arrêt
gabrielle chanel etc qui a clos au tout
début du 20e siècle
ok très bien voilà donc vraiment à
visiter c'est une expérience sensorielle
incroyable je ne vois là faut vraiment
aller dans ce grand musée du parfum
merci pour ces explications alors
maintenant deuxième actualité brûlante
archifaux l'ennui ce que demain sort
votre neuvième livre que je montre la
faune voit la couverture à l'écran voilà
sur le la saga guerre-là comme on peut
dire le roman des guerres la wii leur
monde également parce qu'en fait il
voulait c'est une histoire vraie
évidemment mais elle est tellement
romanesque que
la saga roux était un petit peu stricte
comme déclinera donc vraiment moi j'ai
voulu leur le racontait comme comme une
histoire de famille avant tout ce qu'on
appelle un roman vrai un roman vrai
voilà ce qui n'a comme vous avez déjà
fait on va revenir juste en arrière de
seconde avec jean-luc argent ne pas fait
mme marie antoinette
j'ai pris quelle optique avec ce premier
livre est bien de mettre en scène ce
parfumeur s'avère pas uniquement
raconter sa biographie mais la faire
vivre et d'ailleurs quand le livre a été
sorti il ya en 2005 déjà les
journalistes ma vie dit mme on attend la
suite
et pour moi la suite c'était finalement
ce fondateur de la maison guerlain
pierre et pascal guerlain qui naît à
aviles en 1798 et qui va fondée à paris
en 1828 cette immense maison guerlain
qui de père en fils de grand père en
petit fils va perdurer et traversé des
siècles pour enchanter les femmes les
hommes et voilà bénéfiquement oui donc
vous avez eu cette idée déjà vous dire
quand même on peut le dire que votre
parfum de prédilection c'est l'heure
bleue vous avez un lien particulier avec
avec maison guerlain ou un parfum de
vous porter depuis tout petit
oui depuis tout petit depuis l'âge de 16
ans mais oui depuis le moment où ma mère
m'avait dit qu'il fallait choisir un
parfum de grandes et les parfums que la
vendeuse me présentais ne convenait pas
tout à fait et en allant vers le stand
guerlain jeu d'abord je lis les
des parfums l'accord chalinargues
couleur bleue et ça me faisait rêver
voilà en section littéraire et forcément
ça par la scène est parfaite elle m'ont
arrêté aujourd'hui encore quand vous
mettez tous les matins vous sentez
encore elle ressent moins parce qu'en
fait ensuite le sens de l'odorat ses
secrets survie voilà où par définition
vous sentez ce qui est nouveau ce qui
différencie c'est un danger voilà moi je
reconnais mes temps en temps je ne le
porte pas pendant quelques jours outre
le désert de effet je le retrouve sur
les vêtements
ah oui donc on peut raconter donc en
quelques mots cette ce roman d guerlain
ou milan pierre françois pascal lui il a
démarré comme commis en vendant des
délinquants mais rappelle des parfums
déjà oui c'était ce qu'on appelle déjà
les parfums en fait des produits
parfumerie on va dire oui pour les
grandes maisons d'époque et thé la
grille art et puis aussi dit cet hiver
il a parcouru l'europe
incroyable ce jeune homme qui était
pourtant bien né puisque sa famille
était une famille d'artisans son père
était potier d'étain abbeville marchands
d'épicés également la rolls mais cette
position de majors des pistes qu'il a
baigné petit déjà dans des odeurs
absolument exotiques
c'est un fait qui tapissent a fait son
chemin avec ses fils il a établi à paris
oui ils ont commencé à créer des ce
qu'on appelait les vinaigres non ça
c'était avant même tout seul parce que
en fait il part d'abord il est tout
jeune
finalement il a pas envie de vivre cette
vie de province il avait encore plein la
tête il va partir et il part donc ils se
font embaucher
il a et découvre les réalités du terrain
et aussi surtout tout ce qu'il faut pas
faire et donc il va fonder seule la
bande son entreprise en 1828 et plus
tard en 1864 ses deux fils
aimer et gabriel le rejoindront et sakho
ainsi que ils vont fonder aussi cette
cette entité familiale
c'est une dynastie ou finalement chaque
membre de la famille va travailler dans
l'entreprise en fonction de son talent
d'abord ils doivent tous savoir faire
ils vont ensuite se consacrer au domaine
qui leur convient le mieux d'accord donc
ce sont bien eux qui ont commencé à
introduire les essences de synthèse oui
avec ginger ont expliqué qu'ils lisent
toujours d'ailleurs ou pas bien sûr dit
qu'il était toujours est alors un peu
avant en 1974 il avait créé un parfum
qui s'appelait par rosa qui n'existe
plus beaucoup et il avait déjà introduit
les notes de synthèse
mais à l'époque aimé guérin ne sais pas
le dire ce que c'est très mal vu
d'abonnés il avait dit qu'il avait
utilisé des tuteurs invisible nocebo -
là comme l'expression ouais ouais et
donc tous ces parfums qui sont toujours
existant et et portait encore
aujourd'hui je pense à vol de nuit bien
sûr que saint-exupéry
mais c'est ok ils ont tous mais en fait
ce qu'il faudrait faire
bon il faut lire ce livre qui est
passionnant et qui écrit et cosmos
régale c'est ça coule tout seul et on
apprend plein de choses même sur
l'évolution industrielle économique de
cette période du dîner les nains et
femmes aussi l'évolution d'espacé la
modernité qui arrive voilà une histoire
de galles ainsi ils soient des femmes 6
à de pareilles oui et d'ailleurs c'est
rigolo puisque chacun chaque homme de la
famille gerlach va créer un parfum pour
la femme dont il est amoureux
oui absolument et en fait c'est une
histoire d'homme parce que c'est
vraiment des créateurs masculin mais
derrière il ya toutes ces muses qu'elle
soit lointaine où on comptera tout
proche comme lily bernanke est l épouse
de jacques est un immense créateur garde
un vrai pour qui il a créé notamment
leurs bleus et puis beaucoup d'autres
parfums voit la rue jacques guerlain
avait dit à son petit fils on ne crée
des parfums que pour les femmes que l'on
aime
voilà avec qui le vit donc c'est assez
joli et on sent les faits les femmes
très proche parce que la pâte et parfums
il ya aussi la beauté en écho son oui
alors amerell sont passés à la beauté et
ils ont proposé tout un tas toute une
gamme de produits pour avoir la peau
plus claire celica nivea s'est quand
même game c'est ce que j'ai vu c'est lui
qui a vendu nivea aux allemands il a
vendu le nom exact on découvre plein de
choses super rigolote est vraiment
intéressante
et aussi si on veut plus se pencher dans
ce monde mystérieux des parfums moi je
recommande de lire votre livre avant la
bible pas le livre les parfums chez
bouquins
voilà la collection bouquins alors ça
c'est un pur bonheur parce que on prend
le nom des parfums et vous expliquer
n'oubliez pas le parfum que portel et
les marraines de guerre mot pendant les
guerres de mines d'or c'est nous on m'a
oublié leur petit fille elle au front il
ya tout des histoires complètement
magique et poétique et c'est un bon
complément je trouve à la guerre là oui
tout à fait c'est vrai bon merci à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures des
livres des parfums onimusha change
je ne sais pas on vous en parle en tout
cas je serai toujours très heureux de
venir sur le plateau est adorable et
puis il faut faire en allant comme dit
guerlain exactement alors là non ne
jamais se décourager au bon peuple que
ça
[Musique]